the newest adaptation of Stephen King's
it took a few creative liberties with
the story setting and events so it's
probably no surprise that some of the
characters described in the 1986 novel
don't come through quite the same as
they'd been written
although the losers and their nemesis is
certainly carry the spirit of the source
material through to the big screen let's
take a look at how they stack up to the
books original descriptions built in bro
Jaden Lieber here was previously seen in
Midnight Special and showtimes masters
of sex before becoming bill den bro for
it bill also known as stuttering bill is
the de facto leader of the losers Club
and is described as having a goofball
grin and anxious blue eyes he's also the
tallest and most authoritative member of
the group after the group's childhood
years he later be compared to a teenage
JFK for his reddish hair on-screen
Liebherr hair looks quite different than
the bill described in the book he's not
particularly taller or more imposing
than the others but he still makes it
clear he's the one who's lost the most
and has the most at stake down in the
sewers
he doesn't have book Bill's shock of red
hair either considering he manages to
pull off Bill's passion for the
Pennywise chase however it still works
Richie Tozier stranger things star Finn
wolf are doubled down on his 80's horror
appeal by starring as Richie Tozier the
scrawny bespectacled kid who makes up
for what he lacks in size with zingers
in the book Richie is described as
having such oversized teeth that he
earns the nickname Bucky beaver and has
lenses so thick that he'd be blind
without them those glasses are also
constantly being broken dropped kicked
and bent in the book and they're almost
always lopsided and mended with tape and
his mouth constantly gets him into
trouble which is what earns in the
childhood nickname trash mouth since
most of the books physical descriptions
of Richie revolve around his glasses and
choppers wolf's heart is halfway there
to perfection he might not have those
prominent teeth but his specs and sass
are definitely on point Ben Hanscom
relative newcomer Jeremy ray Taylor may
be familiar to fans of the Marvel
Universe thanks to his role as a bully
in ant-man in its however he made a
change of pace by playing Ben Hanscom
the boy who's actually on the receiving
end of so many taunts Ben is described
as wearing very loose-fitting clothes
because of the constant
ridicule he receives for his weight
inside he's very sweet intelligent and
dependable dude
but all anyone can see when they look at
him is his size he's estimated away
around 150 to 160 pounds and seems quite
insecure about his appearance in the
role tailor pulls off not just the
physical attributes of Ben but the
emotional presence of the character as
well Beverly Marsh Sophia Lillis is a
relative newcomer to the movie business
but fans of it won't soon forget her
name starring as Beverly Marsh the lone
Lady of the losers Club Lillis manages
to bring forth some of the subtler
qualities of her character that hadn't
quite been seen in the 1990 TV
mini-series adaptation in Stephen King's
original version Beverly is described as
being less financially fortunate than
the others a fact that comes through in
her wardrobe with her thrift store
clothes and scuffed shoes from the boys
perspective she's described as being
very pretty with hair that is long in
Auburn eyes that are greyish green and a
pale complexion she's also got a
smattering of freckles and a smile that
is seen as being quote wise cynical and
sad all at the same time for all those
reasons Lily's casting is essentially
perfect although her long hair does look
a little false at the beginning of the
movie she still pulls off the look with
convincing poise more importantly she
captured the subtle strength and world
weariness that made the characters such
a force in the novel eddie kasparek Jack
Dillon grazier capped a brief string of
early supporting roles with a part of
Eddie kasparek wanna build a chart er
member of the losers Club most of kings'
descriptions of Eddie Center around his
asthma plagued by his helicopter mom
he's small slight and fragile even as an
adult what his face is described as thin
and delicate looking Eddie doesn't get
much of a physical description in the
book so there weren't many ways the
filmmakers could go wrong while grazers
Eddie looks entirely different than the
1990s version he still captures his
characters apparent frailties while
still being a lot stronger than he looks
Mike Hanlon Hawaii five-o fetch shows
and Jacobs traded the tropics for Maine
when he took on the role of it's Mike
Hanlon a farm kid growing up on the
outskirts of town Mike is from the only
black family in Derry and is constantly
tormented by Henry Bowers and his bully
Kru as described in the book mike has
been toughened up by physically
laborious work and is fast agile and
slim Jacobs is a brilliant casting
choice for Mike not only does he have
the big tough farm kid physicality in
play but he also has an emotional
vulnerability that makes his narrative
arcs so much more interesting to watch
unfold Stan URIs you might recognize
Wyatt Olaf as the young star-lord in the
guardians of the galaxy movies but
there's no doubt everyone will remember
him now as Stanley URIs from it in the
book Stanley is described as having
black hair and a nose that doesn't quite
suit the stereotype for a person of the
Jewish faith he's also a little older
than the other children due to being
held back a grade as a kid Olaf's
version doesn't have the black hair that
Stan's described to have in the novel
but he does have the fussy mannerisms
neatness and sense of shaking faith down
to a science
Henry Bowers its secondary antagonist
Henry Bowers is only 12 in the book but
he looks much bigger to the losers
because of the fact that he's flunked
enough to still be in their same grade
unlike the film which moves the action
to the 80s the book is set in the 50s
and Henry is the embodiment of the
prototypical bully from that era with a
flattop haircut a pink motorcycle jacket
and the physical wear of his father's
heavy hand for the 2017 version Nicholas
Hamilton's Henry Bowers got a complete
wardrobe overhaul to match the new time
period and instead of the slick
hairstyle he sports a mullet the new
Henry Bowers is just as classically mean
as prior versions though so that's what
counts
Patrick Hawks Tedder although Henry
Bowers was bad enough his sidekick
Patrick was really horrible at his core
played by Owen Teague from blood line in
Black Mirror Patrick is the student who
triggers a whole different level of fear
in those he terrorizes with his
wandering hands and pencil case full of
dead flies in the novel he's heavyset
with a slack and pallid moon face one of
his teachers even describes him as a big
lump of clay that had been crudely
fashioned and looked like a boy
he's also the kind of completely
deranged guy who would murder his infant
brother in his crib Teague who already
had a slew of credits to his name looks
nothing like the heavyset expressionless
preteen in the book and in the film
version the essence of the character has
been dialed down dramatically to the
point that he's really no more than
schoolyard bully with an aerosol fire
gun Pennywise although he's scary in his
own right bill scars guards Pennywise
represents a significant visual change
from the novel his new costuming was
inspired by Elizabethan and medieval era
clown and jester costumes rather than
the baggy silver suit with orange
buttons that's described in King's book
King also describes him as having yellow
eyes and reminds poor Georgie of Bozo
the Clown
he's later compared to Ronald McDonald
for his painted white face and massive
smile and in addition to his long sharp
teeth
he's also mostly bald except for an
orangish red tuft of hair on each side
of his head
the Pennywise of the movie doesn't quite
resemble what King originally imagined
but he's still the kind of clown you
wouldn't want to run across at a
carnival
so it works thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all the
school stuff we know you'll love to